good morning everyone and welcome to the
videos for CISSP security in this video
we will discuss what the CISSP is all
about that different domains that are
covered in the CISSP course what exactly
do we mean by information security then
you are going to have a discussion on
whether abilities threat and risk we are
going to describe each and every term
and you're going to see how they are
related to each other after which we'll
tie that up with discussing risk
management and we'll then identify the
rules and responsibilities of the
management in the information security
space so let's begin with the first
topic of this video
what is cissp now the CISSP stands for
the certified information systems
security professional this is a gold
standard in information security as far
as certifications are concerned and is
normally gained by professionals with
experience of more than five to ten
years and is more of a management
related certification this certification
ensures that you have the requisite
knowledge to become an information
assurance professional where you can
implement security in an organization
and an enterprise now on an enterprise
scale for the exam there are two ways to
go about with the exam anyone can
attempt the exam but once you clear the
exam there is a verification that that
takes place from the ISE square which is
the certification Authority for cissp
where you have to prove that you have at
least five years of experience in the
information security field in at least
two of the domains that are specified on
the CISSP if you do not have that
experience you can still get certified
as an associate of is C square and then
they give you six years to complete the
relevant experience that is required
after which you become a cissp certified
professional the exam is quite difficult
it's known as a mile-wide inch-deep exam
because you don't have to be a master in
each and every domain but you have to
understand how have the knowledge across
all these domains that are specified the
exam is quite tough and people need a
long time to ready themselves for this
exams the passing rate for the candidate
in the very first attempt is well below
50% now this should not be taken as a
negative point the reasons are plentiful
because there
people who actually do not realize the
exam itself or do not realize the
seriousness of the exams people without
experience without reading the requisite
books think that is just going to be a
theological exam and thus they try to
attempt it without being ready for it
right when you want to take the exam
people study for months together and
they solve a lot of question banks
ensure that they have the prerequisite
knowledge so they read a lot of books
that are out there some of them are
prescribed by Isis where themselves
others are from different authors that
they try to give in more insight to
certain topics and then once they feel
that they are ready they would give the
exam I've seen people take question
banks of at least two to three thousand
questions ensure that they're scoring at
least 80% in those tests exams and then
attempt the exam itself so in CISSP as
with every security course we start off
with the CIA triad
now here CIA is confidentiality
integrity and availability so it starts
off with every security mechanism when
we talk about security and we want to
keep things secure what is it that we
want to secure it is the data of an
organization that is the most valuable
asset to the organization and that's
what we want to secure when we say that
we want the data to be secured we
basically talk about three aspects for
that data the first and the foremost
that the data needs to remain
confidential the second aspect that the
traitor needs to be trustworthy and the
third concept that the data should be
available to all authorized users when
and where they require it so going back
to the first point when we say we want
data to be confidential what do we mean
by that by confidentiality we talk about
that data being made available only to
authorized users after you have
authenticated them insured or assured of
their authenticity and only then you're
going to give access to that data right
so even if you go into an organization
an organization has a hierarchy of
governance right so only certain people
with certain clearances or certain job
titles can have access to certain amount
of data whereas other people may not
have access to it for example a person
working in the sales department will not
have access to data that is accessed by
the HR department thus that's what we
are looking at classification of data
and keeping it confidential only making
it available to those people who require
it when we say trustworthiness or the
integrity of that data the integrity is
the data has been altered modified
removed deleted by unauthorized people
so we want to prevent that which means
when we say we want the integrity intact
we want to ensure that only authorized
people can modify alter or remove data
if they are allowed to do so so that's
what the authorization and
authentication comes into the picture
again and data needs to be available for
me to safeguard data I can just lock it
up in a safe through the safe in the
depth of an ocean and say that the data
is secure because it cannot be leaked
out but that data is no longer available
to authorized users hence the data is
useless for me data would have value
when the data remains confidential has
its trustworthiness intact and is still
available to all the users that are
authorized to access it so when we talk
about security we want these three
aspects to be implemented on any and
every digital asset that the
organization has and thus once these
three points are guaranteed or at least
assured to a certain extent we can then
say that the data or that particular
asset is secured so when we talk about
CIS espied what are the domains in cissp
as far as the exam and the certification
is concerned and how will CIA or
information security related to it so to
start off with there are eight domains
in cissp one starts off with asset
security then you've got security
architecture and engineering then we
have communication and network security
Identity and Access Management secure
the operations security assessment and
testing software development security
and security and risk management
all right so talking about the eight
domains the first one being security and
risk management this is from a
governance perspective where we talk
about the risk an organization would
face risk management a little bit talk
about compliance laws regulations that
the organization has to look forward to
or needs to adhere to so if you look at
an organization's
from an organization's perspective you
are looking at a business objective that
an organization has and how security can
be aligned with the business objectives
for example if you take an online
retailer or as we call them in a tailor
and we want to look at how security is
relevant to them right we first want to
look at what are the compliances or what
are the laws the country has in which
they exist and what laws do they need to
adhere to could be corporate loss could
be computing loss could be the
Information Technology Act that we have
in India or the privacy acts that we
have across the world GDP are
that is required regulations for example
a financial organization would need to
comply with gdpr
if they're in Europe or if they're in
USA California there's a California act
that's there for privacy the security
that they want to deal with so if they
want to implement ISO 27001 on top of
that what are the requirements for ISO
27000 what is the scope of that standard
that can be implemented in their
organization so they want to check on
these laws or regulations compliances
and they need to check which they need
to implement and which they need to
adhere to and once they have identified
that they would look at the risk
assessment they would see where they are
positioned right now what are the risks
that the organization faces as far as
these laws regulations and compliances
are concerned how they can mitigate
those risks with security and one
security has been implemented how they
can move on with the governance of that
enterprise over a longer period of time
and then this is broken down into rest
of the modules where you can first talk
about asset security so you first want
to identify the assets of an
organization could be physical assets
like computers servers storage servers
switches routers see how they can be
secured physical security comes into the
picture as well then you want to look at
our digital assets like the data that is
being stored classification of data
maybe a little bit where you have
identified data you have classified them
as proprietary data something that is
trademarked something that is
copyrighted etc the value of those
assets that the organization has towards
them and then how you want to protect
that asset based on the risk assessment
strategy that you have identified in the
first domain then comes with the third
module security engineering now this is
very security by design starts as far as
cissp is concerned cissp always
encourages security to be involved at
each and every phase of the lifecycle of
an organization so for example the third
domain we'll start off with enterprise
architectures like TOGAF and how
security architectures like ISO 27001 or
isoprene 7,000 two three four five of
any of these standards or qubits for
example can be implemented and
integrated with the enterprise
architecture thus giving you a good
security architecture right from the
inception point so the main aspect being
security should not be bolted on it
should be secured by design which means
why you are creating it and implementing
it security should be implemented
right from then then we move on to the
next module module for communications
and network security so in the previous
module you have identified the devices
that you have talked about how the
architecture of those devices would be
how data flows are going to happen and
then how you're going to secure those
data flows then you come to the
communication and networking part of it
how these come computers or devices are
going to interact with each other which
protocols are going to be utilized the
OSI layer comes into the picture how
you're going to secure yourself against
various network based attacks like ARP
spoofing Mac's spoofing IP address
spoofing sniffing attacks
man-in-the-middle attacks and things
like that
now this domain is slightly technical
does it does talk about OSI layers TCP
and UDP but it doesn't good in depth
about technicalities about how attacks
are created or how attacks are executed
right so that's something that this
training doesn't deal with so this is
not a hacking training where you're
actually going to learn how to hack it's
basically a overview of what threats or
risks a network or a communication
protocols may have and thus you're going
to identify the relevant security
controls and implement them on those
particular levels so for example in this
mechanism I want the OSI layer which has
seven layers right from the physical
layer to the application layer and then
I want to identify a particular attack
and which layer it affects and does want
to have a proprietary control to monitor
that layer so as to mitigate that
particular attack right so it's
semi-technical if you will where you
need to understand the OSI layer and the
protocols but you don't need to execute
those attacks at all then comes the
Identity and Access Management so if you
have seen if you go back to security and
risk management and you have talked
about CIA confidentiality integrity
availability and then we have talked
about identifying assets engineering
with security as a design that working
and all those now when we come back to
confidentiality and we want to keep
these things confidential how do we do
that the first thing is identity and
access management so who is allowed to
access what to what extent are they
allowed and what are they authorized to
do are they allowed to modify those
particular data points delete remove
them or add to them edit them etc so
who's authorized to do what and once
they are authorized you want the
authentication mechanism come to come in
so we come back to the I Triple A
standards identification authentication
authorization and accountability so when
I say I want user who has been through
the identity and access management
process and only then will they be
allowed to access that's where your user
management comes into the picture for
example let's take Gmail everybody
accesses Gmail what is it that you first
do you open up a browser that's where
your asset security comes in the browser
becoming that asset where you need to
secure it so you secure it by having and
efficient toolbars maybe an anti-virus
and things like that the security
engineering coming into the picture
where you have integrated a particular
browser with some particularly
extensions how the browser is going to
communicate using HTTP HTTPS right and
then when you go to Google you use the
Identity and Access Management module so
it first asks you to identify yourself
by using your username so you type in
your email address that's your identity
so that's the I Triple A identity coming
into picture then it asked for
authentication which is your password
you may have enabled multi-factor
authentication at that point in time so
once you put in the password if it's
single authentication mechanisms you
enter it and then that's why your
authentication process comes into the
picture after that is the authorization
process what are you authorized to
access as a user do you get access to
the entire Gmail server no you only get
access to the email account that you
have been authorized to access within
that if you're an administrator to that
account you can do whatever you want and
they are still monitored that's where
the accountability part comes into the
picture where if you do something
illegal you may be penalized for it so
that's that Identity and Access
Management mode you that comes into the
picture
now with the browser I've just given you
a very basic example but as you go into
a larger scenario we are looking at
enterprises and you're looking at
security over different assets like
storage databases and so on so forth it
becomes a huge task to have an identity
access management mode you will
implement it then comes the next domain
called security operations so that's
where your day-to-day operations like a
sock a security operation center comes
into the picture so incident management
disaster recovery your investigations
for in six of what what attacks have
happened so your security operation
centers might be the day-to-day
activities that you deal with let's say
ids/ips firewalls anti viruses and it's
basically a structure of how you are
going to build an exercise to manage
incidents as and when they happen so
it's basically more of
operation scenario where you're looking
at the day-to-day health of an
organization rather than looking at
overview of the security of an
organization then comes security
assessment and testing which is
basically your secure development
lifecycle or as DLCs as they're known
there you'll be looking at how you can
assess applications where you'll be
looking at SAS - or dynamic application
security testing static application
security testing and so on so forth so
here you're either procured an
application from a third party and you
want to test their application to see
how it is going to or what risks it is
going to expose your business to or you
are developing an application and you
want to involve security right from the
inception so if you're looking at that
then you can move on to the next domain
way we talk about software development
security which talks about different
software development lifecycle models
like waterfall a giant spiral models and
so on so forth so if you look at the
eight domains they basically start off
with the governance where they talk
about security and rescue management and
they go to each and every aspect of your
information technology and give you an
overview of how security should be
implemented right from the inception and
build up from there to the execution
level now the exam and these domains are
built in ideal world not a real world
scenario so there are a few assumptions
over here where you assume that you have
all the quiet resources you have all the
required people to do those jobs you're
living in an ideal world you have mapped
all the rules and responsibilities
properly and then you're talking about
these eight domains in the real world
things are quite different and people
who have got real world experience kind
of struggle to map all those things as
far as an ideal world is concerned and
that's where your reading and your
understanding of these concepts come
into the picture moving on let's talk
about information security information
security is the process of protecting
data and information system so in the
CIA as we talked about it when we said
what do we want to protect we want to
protect all the information assets or
the technical assets that we have from
any of the volubility that can be
identified so we want to restrict
unauthorized access and use we want to
restrict deletion accidental or
intentional if they have not been
authorized to do so
modification of data so the integrity
part and destruction of data this start
could not only be deleting data but it
could be something like a ransomware
where the data gets encrypted so it's
still there it's just not accessible to
you now information security ensures the
implementation of these following
aspects the first and foremost comes
from information security policies which
is the governance aspect of it the
policies are designed to have a
implementation of security in an
organization that helps the business
processes to be executed in a secure
manner where are these policies coming
from they come from standards or
guidelines which are globally available
and based on which we can start
developing our security policies for
example if I want to develop a security
policy in my organization I might want
to depend on frameworks like ISO 27001
COBIT or something similar once I have
these standards set I would come back to
procedures procedures being how are
these standards to be executed right for
example in my policies I ensured that I
want encryption of AES 256 to be
implemented or rather in the policy I
determine that we want encryption to be
implemented on a Teta set because based
on the classification of those data so
you know policies I would determine how
the classification is going to work how
data is going to be classified on what
parameters and thus once the data gets
classified we are going to come back to
standards where we say if it is
classified as a confidential data we
want to use encryption to protect that
data and we want a yes 256 to be in a
utilize for encryption so how do we go
about it how do we implement the
encryption that's where your procedures
come into the picture your guidelines
are troubleshooting mechanisms optional
documents so if somebody has trouble
following the procedures they might want
to go into the guidelines and see how to
troubleshoot the scenario that they are
facing baselines are basically the
minimum achievable target that you want
to go with with these policies so let's
say when I say I want to have a baseline
on a server where for the server to be
published on to the internet or to be
used in production environment it has to
meet a certain criteria which means I
can go back to the hardware and I can
say the server needs a hardware
configuration of XY and Z let's say a
processor a xeon processor with 16 cores
128 gigs of ram so that's a baseline
that i need for a particular server for
it to be put in the production
environment for a particular use
anything above that is accept
but nothing should go below that then
comes a risk-management while we are
implementing these policies procedures
we have those standards in place if we
face any risk during that period or if
we face any threat or availabilities
identified during this period all these
terms you are going to discuss in a
little bit so when we identify whole
abilities or threats that's where our
risks come into the picture the risk
management comes in saying okay this is
a risk that we have identified and now
how do we want to mitigate the risk then
the security organization comes into the
picture the day-to-day activity of how
security is to be implemented and for
all of these procedures policies
baseline standards to be implemented to
be ensured that there ought to be
assured that they are working properly
we need to make our employees aware that
these policies exist this is something
that they need to follow
thus the of eminence or the security
education comes into the picture here
the security education is more focused
on helping employees adhere to the
company policies and standards rather
than educating employees about security
we don't want to make everybody ethical
hacker we just want to ensure them or we
want to assure the organization that
everybody has been warned about policies
procedures security requirements and
they are going to follow those
requirements for example a password
policy where you have to adhere to a
specific password policy to ensure
passwords are created at the same time
there is another password policy which
says that you should not share passwords
with your colleagues no matter what so
for me for my employees to follow that I
need to make them aware that these
policies exist and there are
repercussions if they do not follow
these particular policies so coming back
to the governance part what is
governance since we have been talking
about it governance ensures that the
security strategies are aligned with
business objectives and consistent with
regulations so what does it guarantee
appropriate information security
activities are being performed based on
what based on the policies that we have
created based on the standards that we
have and the baselines that we would
have created so security has to be
comparable right so if I say I have
secured against particular attacks the
attacks have to be identified and then
compared to those particular attacks I
can say I have mitigated these
activities by having specific security
controls thus I can say that I am secure
the governance aspects keeps a watch on
all the security controls to see that
those security activity
are insured are being implemented and
are performing to the best of their
abilities that's where your governance
comes into the picture the risks being
reduced so the risk management as also
comes under the governance where you are
looking at newly identified risks and
you're then implementing security
controls that would mitigate these risks
then you're looking at information
security investments appropriately
directed so when I say I want to
security control which would be a
firewall ids/ips antiviruses whatever is
required it needs to have a return on
investment which is acceptable for the
organization you don't want to spend up
to much of money in security thus
creating losses for the organization
when you say a business a business
objective is always to make money rather
than use money so security should be a
supporting feature to the business
objectives where the services are being
provided by the business in a secure
manner in such a way that they can still
have a positive return on investment on
the services that are being provided and
the executive management can determine
the program's effectiveness this is the
major part because we have to even in
any compliances or its technical audits
we have to prove that whatever we have
implemented actually works is effective
does mitigating the risk if your
security controls are not effective then
you have just wasted a bucketload of
money and have not achieved any security
measures in your exercise moving on to
security controls security controls are
measures taken to safeguard an
information system from an attack
basically for the CIA triad confidential
and integrity and availability so
security controls could be
administrative controls technical
controls of physical security controls
what our administrative security
controls they would be policies
procedures that we have in place so the
password policy becomes an
administrative control where the
management has made everybody aware that
the password needs to mean a particular
complexity should not be shared and thus
becomes an administrative security
control a technical security control
would be where we are implementing this
policy and thus when I try to create a
password there is a software that map's
the password to the complexity
requirements asurs or ensures that the
complexity requirements have been met
and thus allows the password to be
accepted or retakes the password as the
case may be that is a security control a
physical security control may be let's
say a CCTV camera which
going to use to monitor people and
ensure that nothing untoward happens
it's not only against physical crime but
let's say access to a particular room
where nobody is seen tailgating maybe
monitoring a server room which is very
well secured and ensuring that
unauthorized people do not get access or
purposefully or intently do not access
that area at all times so these are the
three levels of security controls that
can be implemented to enhance the
security of an organization then we come
to security policies policies is an
overall broad statement produced by a
senior management that dictates the role
of security within the organization for
example the password policy that we
talked about it just said that it needs
to meet a certain complexity which is a
broad statement that is being made by a
by the management saying we want to
adhere to this policy to ensure that we
do not get hacked by brute-force attacks
or dictionary attacks or whatever it is
the broad statement is trying to prevent
certain attacks from happening on the
organization how it is implemented
that's where the procedures and
everything else comes into the picture
it must integrate security into all
business processes so if I start
creating a policy which shows that the
complexity should be so high that the
password should be at least 20
characters strong that would be
detrimental to the organization's health
because people may not remember those
passwords or resetting those passwords
or having technical mechanisms technical
security controls in place to implement
that kind of stringent security may be
too expensive to have so whatever
policies are created they need to be in
line with the business processes as well
the policy must be reviewed and modified
periodically or S company changes so as
and when the company becomes more mature
and can have more levels of security
they must look at their policies again
and redefine them or as a company grows
or changes market scenarios or changes
business processes these policies may
become redundant so you want to look at
those policies and implement new
policies or modify the existing policies
to suit the business processes in a
better manner it must support vision and
mission of the organization a business
once established will always have a long
term vision for example the e-tailer
example that we are talking about for me
to open an e taylor key retailing
website i don't want it to be periodic I
don't want it to be for a month or so
I want to achieve success in that factor
and I want to create a plan of where I
want to reach let's say in the next five
years so how do I achieve that that's
something that I need to plan as a
business plan all my security mechanism
that are in place should be in alignment
with the business plans business visions
across the number of years that we have
envisaged the business to perform so
that's where the policies coming into
picture policies are always long-term
not short-term documents but need to be
periodically reviewed and modified as
the business grows or business changes
its pusher then looking at compliance
compliance means confirming to a rule
such as a specification policy standard
or law so we have looked at compliance
from a perspective where we talked about
ISO 27001 or PCI DSS or those frameworks
now these are not laws but these are
standards of frameworks that have been
created over a period of time through
experience and these are targeted
towards organizations towards specific
industries for example PCI DSS is only
towards finance organizations where they
have payment gateways in place the ISO
27001 is a more generic policy which can
be implemented by various organizations
HIPAA Health Insurance Portability and
Accountability Act is an American actor
talks about a health-related data of its
citizens so these are compliance is
these may not be laws but you need to
adhere to these to be effective and to
be allowed to conduct business in that
particular industry then we have code of
ethics code of ethics state safety of
the Commonwealth duty to our principles
and to each other requires that we
adhere and be seen to adhere to the
highest ethical standards of behavior
therefore strict adherence to this code
is a condition of certification what are
the ethics protect society the
Commonwealth and the infrastructure act
honorably honestly justly responsibly
responsibility and legally through
diligent and competent service to the
principles advance and profession now
the code of ethics our codes created by
IC square for the CISSP professional and
you need to adhere to these codes if
they identify violation of these codes
from any member david d by the members
stripped them of the certification and
even black
based on whatever thinks they have
violated so even before the exam you
have to go through the code of ethics
you have to accept the code of ethics in
the exam you make it get up to five to
six questions just on code of ethics
then comes the legal systems that's
where the law comes into the picture law
could differ from country to country or
from region to region and thus depending
on which country you're in you may need
to be aware of those laws of those
countries as far as cissp is concerned I
see Square is concerned they are an
American organization so they would talk
about mostly American laws and a few
European laws or directives as well so
there are three different laws that we
talk about civil common and religious
laws depends on the country the culture
of that particular country the
information security professional should
understand the different legal systems
followed internationally so you also may
come across the classification as civil
law criminal law and law of torts civil
law is basically a law where let's say a
contract has been breached and it's not
criminal in nature you just want to sue
an organization for breach of contract
criminal law is where something criminal
has happened under the particular act of
that particular country like let's say a
murder or an attack that has happened a
physical attack or something got stolen
and the third one was the law of torts
where it's more of a compensatory law
where you can file a case a civil suit
demand compensation in lieu of the
wrongs that have happened to that
particular organization or that
individual then comes the personal
security the person law the people
inside the organization need access to
data to complete the signed work and
hence of the potential to misuse these
privileges and thus you should have
personal security as well now when we
talk about hiring practices for people
most of the organizations perform
frantic background checks and we get
confused by these background checks are
being done the background checks are
essential to the health of the
organization where you are ensuring that
the person is not a malicious person has
the prerequisite certifications or the
qualifications have never been debarred
or have never been prosecuted do not
have a criminal background thus
preventing
physical attacks on the organization for
example competitor may attempt to place
in your organization a spy to spy to
gather information on the secrets of the
domination and to put it back to the
company to a background check
may reveal that this person was
previously employed by a competitor and
thus you might want to verify that the
how that employment got terminated when
did it get terminated or is this person
misusing anything or misrepresenting any
aspect of his or their life then you
also need to get confidentiality
agreement signed with them for example
in DA's non-disclosure agreements data
that is being shared with them the
ownership of that particular data and
what are the repercussions if that
confidentiality is breached by that
particular person conflict of interest
agreements for positions handling
competitive information as you go higher
up in the organization you might come
across contracts where it prohibits a
particular portion in engaging an act
into the same activity with a competitor
for a particular period of time so if
there is a conflict of interest when you
are hiring a person where they have
signed and such a agreement with another
competitor or another organization you
don't want to embroil yourself in a
lawsuit where the other organization may
sue you for hiring a person while they
were still under that particular
contract so it's not only to look at the
background of these people but to
safeguard the organization from any
lawsuits or any violations of content as
well get the non-compete agreements for
the positions in charge of unique
corporate processes that again goes on
to say if you're going to leave the
organization you cannot start up a
competing business similar to the
organization's business and so on so
forth
now let's come back to the technical
aspect and start talking about
vulnerability threats and risk now what
is a vulnerability it is nothing but a
weakness in a system or a process
implies the absence of a countermeasure
vulnerabilities internal and is more
easily managed so it's basically a flaw
or a miss configuration or a design flaw
or something like using defaults
username passwords configurations where
if that particular flaw is misused it
will lead into a security event on that
particular device for that particular
organization so when we say that if a
security event it has
to be detrimental in nature so if
somebody is using a weak password that
can easily be tracked that is a
vulnerability where you have identified
a weak password and then you want to
prevent that vulnerability by imposing a
security control or a countermeasure
the security control here starts off
with the policy of having a robust
security policy where a password policy
comes in that describes the complexity
of a particular password and then you
talk about a technical countermeasure
where you have implemented an identity
and access management plan which would
ensure that the person creating that
password adheres to the complexity of
that particular policy then a threat the
threat is the possibility that the
vulnerability might be exploited which
will result in loss so if somebody has
created a weak password and it has been
allowed that's a vulnerability which can
be exploited by the usage of brute-force
attacks or or dictionary based attacks
to crack passwords if the password is
cracked somebody unauthorized may get
access to that data does resulting in a
loss for that organization so the threat
is the possibility of that particular
one of the D being exploited and then
comes the risk the risk is basically the
likelihood of that attack being happened
so I have a weak password it can be
exploited by a for asset exterior attack
the likelihood of that attack is what
determines me the risk level for me now
the likelihood it will always be
hypothetical but we don't want to run
helter-skelter and we do not want to
take the possibility too extreme so
that's where your business processes
come into the picture your security
policies come into the picture based on
the business processes and the policies
implemented if I have a weak password
what would be the loss that I would face
for that particular person for example a
fresher coming into an organization
having a weak password but having
limited access to data it would have a
lesser risk because of the loss being
lesser than a CEO of an organization
using a weak password and thus getting
exploited because the CEO will have
access to more proprietary data that if
God gets into the computers hand would
he lead in huge losses does the same
risk of having a password track for a
fresher will have a lesser loss thus a
lesser risk compared to the same risk to
a CEO where the loss would be higher so
a threat could
so be in multiple aspects threats could
be natural that means two fires flooding
tornadoes anything that is an act of God
that can happen with minimal human
interaction or the second threat would
be man-made where man is responsible for
it like theft hacking writing or
anything that is created by a man or
rather humans and technical in nature
could be software bugs where
vulnerabilities create or created or
server failures where something
technical has gone wrong and you need a
technical errors skilled person to come
in and repair that particular aspect
then the fourth one would be a supply
system failure or a chain supply failure
where you have dependencies for example
any organization will have a dependency
on electricity service provider where
they are providing electricity as a
service which powers on the IT
infrastructure if the service product
feels and there is a electricity or a
power cut your systems are not going to
work thus you need a secondary mechanism
to prevent that threat from being
realized once we have identified these
threats we have identified these
vulnerabilities and we have identified
the likelihood and the probability of
that attack that's where we come across
the risk management exercise now what is
risk management risk management is a
hypothetical exercise where we have
identified a vulnerability we have
looked at the threat that it may have
and the likelihood of that threat being
realized once we have identified the
threat the risk level that's where the
risk management comes into the picture
reading from the slides a core component
of enterprise security program why
because we need a baseline and we
compare security to a baseline for
example I have got a firewall that has
been configured in a particular manner
now when I do a vulnerability assessment
on the firewall it the quality
assessment gives me a report that states
that some of the rules may now be
written dn't thus allowing access to
unauthorized users this becomes a risk
or this becomes a threat if this threat
is identified by unauthorized people
they would then try to attack this
firewall to gain access to that data
which they are unauthorized to access
thus
you are leading to losses for an
organization what is the likelihood of
this happening if the likelihood is high
or low that's what the risk management
program is all about right and based on
this risk we implement security control
we manage the security controls and then
we verify the security controls for
future risks to coming into the picture
it must be defined and it is always
defined as an ongoing project because
the risks will always change based on
the businesses based on the security
controls that you have this will give a
guidance to an organization of how
security is being implemented how it has
enhanced over a period of time and how
security mature that organization has
become because of the risk assessment
program it also helps you to satisfy two
aspects due diligence and you care what
is due diligence due diligence is
basically the research the organization
does in identifying those risks and
mitigating them that you care is the
actual part of mitigation where you have
implemented a security control to
mitigate the risk that you have
identified so if company is negligent
that means if the company doesn't have a
risk management program it is not going
to be that security oriented or the
security is not going to be that great
does the company may not comply to laws
regulations and standards thus causing
them penalties lawsuits and other
repercussions in the industry based on
whatever they are doing for risk
management will come to frameworks the
frameworks are used to categorize
information systems so that we can
identify threats or risks based on the
classification so these classification
helps us determine the criticality and
the sensitivity of information system
right so what is the sensitivity and
criticality it basically gives us an
understanding of the value of the asset
that we have so if you go back to domain
one the asset value or the asset
identification as a security that's
where it comes into the picture
obviously our database server is going
to be more secure than end-user laptop
based on the data that they have thus
the criticality of the system for a
database is much higher than the
end-users laptop then we look at the
security controls that can be
implemented then for those the
frameworks like ISO 27001 comes into the
picture
there is Co bit there is a lot of
frameworks out there NIST 853 then we
talk about accessing the security
controls once we have placed those
security controls we need to verify
those controls are placed properly they
actually mitigate the risk and are
appropriate to correctly mitigate that
particular
resdac they are gated then looking at
authorizing information systems around
information systems operations based on
risk state of mind so you have
identified dress you have authorizing
some of them some of the devices to
function in a particular manner based on
which some of those discs would be
mitigated or would be reduced to an
acceptable level
so in the CISSP we talked about a lot of
risk assessment strategies we look at
how we can manage risks the four
different types of managing risks would
be one is to mitigate other is to
transfer the third is to accept it and
the fourth one is to neglect the rest so
it in the CISSP
it talks in great details about those
risk assessment strategies but we are
talking about the four types of risk
mitigating strategies they are risk
avoiding or avoiding the risks accepting
the risk
transferring the risk and in limiting
the risk so in the course we basically
talk about a lot of risk strategies and
how to mitigate these risks and how they
can be implemented to bring down to a
acceptable level so again this caps
acceptance risk appetite of an
organization comes into the picture
these terms are then discussed in the
training to understand how the policies
would work around the risk management
strategy moving on then looking at
monitoring security control so once we
have security controls in place we have
assist them you also need to monitor
them for the effectiveness and though
they are going to create any alerts or
any risks are being realized or any new
risks that may be created by the
security control implementation so in
these risk assessment these are the
framers these are the steps that we want
to follow to identify mitigate and
monitor these risks so the management
begins with risk assessment what do you
mean by risk assessment identifying the
impact of the risk that the risk would
have on the organization and there would
be two different ways to assess the risk
a quantitative assessment or a
qualitative assessment a quantitative
assessment is more quantifiable or is
numerical in its process they are
looking at assigning costs to particular
assets and the threats so the losses
that you may figure out in a risk
assessment strategy would be more
numerical we're good
in a currency format well let's say a
risk if realized would lead to a loss of
a X amount of dollars that's where the
quantitative analysis comes into the
picture the qualitative analysis would
be quality of a service so if a service
is being affected because of a risk what
is the degradation of that service to
what aspect is it getting rear degraded
for example internet that we use if
there is an internet outage or if there
is a reduction in internet speed right
so if I've got a 10 Mbps line and now
because of some fault of the ISP it gets
reduced to 4 Mbps I may not be able to
conduct the business that I would I was
doing on a 10 Mbps line does the quality
of that device has degraded does it is
going and it does it is a risk and it is
causing me losses right so qualitative
risk analysis would be more descriptive
in nature rather than being numerical in
nature most of the companies or
organizations would follow a hybrid
policy because it is not possible to
have a quantitate quantitative risk
analysis in each and every scenario new
organization which doesn't have much
data to rely on historical data of how
threats have affected that particular
organization may go in for a qualitative
one and as they mature over time in the
security practices they may then turn
over to a quantitative risk analysis or
a hybrid risk analysis where they're
using a combination of quantitative and
qualitative code does the risk controls
that we are talking about risk
acceptance risk reduction and risk
assignment there is risk avoidance as
well so there are four controls the risk
reduction is where you have implemented
a security control based on which the
risk has been reduced to a more
acceptable level risk assignment is
where you're also known as risk
avoidance that's where you're avoiding
risk by outsourcing it so talking about
risk controls again the four types being
accept avoid transfer and reduce risk
acceptance is where your the
organization is willingly accepting the
rest as the way it is because they don't
want to deal with it right now they
might deal it it with it in the next
iteration or it doesn't it is at an
acceptable level and the company just
wants to move on avoiding the risk is
where you are going to try to not use
the service where the risk exists
does avoiding is where you have
identified a particular service where
the risk exists and now you're not using
the service to avoid the risk altogether
risk limitation or risk reduction would
be where you are implementing a security
control to mitigate the risk and then
this transference is where risk
assignment comes into the picture where
you are transferring it to a third party
like outsourcing it by using insurance
to limit the risk so for example the
threat is of a fire the risk is high but
you cannot do anything about it so you
purchase insurance so if the fire
actually happens you would still be
reimbursed for the losses that you have
faced coming back to countermeasures we
have discussed administrative
countermeasures these are policies rules
regulations laws customs that a company
needs to adhere to based on the industry
that they are in then there are
technical control software controls
anything that is technical in nature or
ids/ips firewalls encryption anything
that is going to help you implement the
CIA and then physical where you would
look at locks on those security guards
at offenses where they're preventing
access to unauthorized people let's talk
about roles and responsibilities of
management now as far as management is
concerned or the hierarchy is concerned
you can see on the screen there is a
senior management the security
professional data owner custodian and
user now these are from example spective
from the certification perspective
obviously the hierarchy in an
organization would be slightly different
but here the senior management is the
responsible party for the entire
security mechanism so they must write
the entire security program so CISSP
talks about a top-down approach where
the senior management has realized the
importance of security and is
implementing at all levels within the
organization thus they are a part of it
and they are supporting the security
program they define the tolerance of
risk or how much risk is topping it to
be tolerated by an organization from a
monetary perspective or the qualitative
perspective as well depending on the
laws legislations regulations
compliances and the contracts the
business has signed they will rely on
security professionals to manage the
risk but the exercise and the management
process has to be defined by the
senior management once the security team
comes up with the countermeasures the
senior management either approves or
disapproves them based on the return on
investment of that countermeasure the
security professional assists with the
development of policy documents gives
their input because they are the people
who are in the day-to-day process of
dealing with these does they can
identify gaps and give good inputs to
modify or to clear the policy in a more
robust manner the security professionals
may be a part of the risk assessment and
risk management team as well especially
the security technical aspects of it
assist with the implementation and
maintenance of countermeasures so the
administrative technical or physical
measures that you have identified you
may be requested to implement that for
example the locks that we have on the
door
the swipe locks they are connected to a
database where the database is
maintained so as a security professional
you wouldn't be responsible to fit those
locks but to create the database manage
and maintain the database where that
information is kept upon where people
are authorized and authenticated and
would be responsible for monitoring
auditing and security assessments as
well the data owner the owner of that
particular data part would normally be
the head of the department for example
the sales data is normally owned by the
director of sales of that department so
that they would be ultimately
responsible for identifying that data
classifying that data and accepting the
security controls that are implemented
they may request for additional security
controls if they deem fit the security
professional implements the security
controls then the custodian a person who
is responsible for implementing the
approved security controls or managing
the day-to-day activity of the security
controls for example the security
professional has identified access
control to be implemented on a data set
that a data owner owns the data owner
has a prove of it it is the custodian
who is going to implement that strategy
or implement the control on it the user
is basically the user who or the person
who accesses the information and ID
Resources does whatever access controls
have been implemented would identify the
user authenticate authorize them and
help them account
for whatever they are doing if the user
is unable to authenticate access would
be denied and that's it for this video I
appreciate you watching the entire video
and I'll see you in the next thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here